if you told the majority of the most
ambitious kids in this room that they're
only gonna make a million bucks a year
Max in their career they would think
like they [__] up and so I think
success got reframed into crazy numbers
like you had movies coming out 15 years
ago it's like you know what's better
than a million a billion like you know
it all got weird I think people are
confused out there what's success a
million dollars 10 million dollars 100
million dollars it's a million dollars
like you get to decide what success is
what are some of the things that you
sacrificed to get where you are today
and do you think it's possible to reach
a high level of business success without
immense sacrifice of course it's a
possibility if you decide to Define
business success
at a certain level I would argue that
business that's living and breathing
that is alive and growing that makes the
founder eight hundred thousand dollars a
year is an outrageously successful
business the top one percent earners in
America make 480 000 a year
you're a top one percent
success
and at eight hundred thousand dollars a
year take home from a small business
one does not have to sacrifice in the
way that the question was posed right at
that level you don't have to work 19
hours a day you can have 60 hour work
weeks 45 hour work weeks achieve that
level of financial success
and still have family time and still
have your mental health I mean I don't
think mental health has a number I know
people that are struggling with mental
health that have businesses that do
forty thousand a year and I know people
that have do not have mental health
issues and have good you know
um content happy peace of mind that run
300 million a year businesses so I don't
think Mental Health
has a direct attribute with
guys and scale I think it goes back a
little bit to self-esteem self-awareness
I also think for by show of hands
because I see most of you how many of
you in this class intuitively believe
like
doing business or being an entrepreneur
is as fun to you as like playing sports
or watching TV or skiing or like like
it's like the most fun raise your hand
right so like you know for me that group
is going to struggle to burn out if
their literal favorite thing on earth
and their Hobby and their fun is
business building
of course there's sacrifices but but I
don't know if you know this there's a
lot of people in this classroom
Professor I don't know if you know this
there's a lot of people you and I know
who do not own businesses who are
employees who sacrifice things too
sacrifice is just a reality of life
but you get to decide what success is
right like what's success a million
dollars 10 million dollars 100 million
dollars trillion dollar like like you
know to me why I love entrepreneurship
for me success is being able to do what
you want to do every day
and living within the means of how much
money you have so if you don't have tons
and tons and tons of money well then you
fly private everywhere anytime you want
but having the freedom
to create and do your [__] thing
well that doesn't take that much money
um so you know I think this is a very
complex question I think a lot of kids
are and a lot of grown-ups are confused
by this I I don't think you have to be
unhappy like you know to like win you
know like I think you can build an
Empire on your terms
and in your way I also think people lack
patience I think people want money too
fast I think that hurts them I think
that's where I think people burn out or
sacrifice because they're trying to win
too fast to show everybody that they won
I'm petrified of people thinking
entrepreneurship is cool and like just
doing it because they think it's cool
it's [__] hard when we were growing
up
if you've made a million dollars a year
you [__] you were big time
now like if you told the majority of the
most ambitious kids in this room that
they're only going to make a million
bucks a year Max in their career they
would think like they [__] up oh my
God
and so I think like success got reframed
into crazy numbers like you had movies
coming out saying like Justin
Timberlake's I mean making a movie 15
years ago that's like you know what's
better than a million a billion like
like you know it all got weird and the
separation of wealth and Society has
gotten weird and too extreme and so like
I think people are confused out there
uh hi Gary so just relating to the
concept of failing fast and learning
from your past mistakes how can
individuals reframe their perception of
failure and um use as a tool for growth
and progress a lot of you were of the
generation where
failure started to get demonized
right back to me and Professor being
older like there was no such thing as
any trophy for anybody than besides the
people that won Little League
and so we created a culture in the last
30 40 years where we tried to over
protect people from failure
you know when you when I hear that
question from you I get scared because
when I think about
the school system Society for the last
30 40 years
we didn't do a lot of favors for people
to get comfortable with losing we
demonized it we by over protecting
people from it we made them think it was
bad
humans not gen Z not emerging gen Alpha
not Boomers like humans need to practice
losing a lot more so the answer to the
question is it's easy
go do [__] you'll lose all that
entrepreneurship is is micro losing
with the occasional macro win